okay hi everyone we're here for another
week of science and technology Q&A for
kids and others and I have a slightly
different set up today just for a change
um and we're going to continue talking
about science fiction ideas and what can
be real and what can't be and the
science and technology behind them so
let's take a look at some some of the
questions that are coming in here okay
oh here's an interesting question um
what will science fiction look like in
20 years and how does the past compared
to today that's an interesting question
so I first thing I should say is a bit
of a disclaimer here I'm I am i watch
movies I don't watch television
I don't read science fiction books so uh
least not much um so my my information
on this will be mostly based on talking
about movies let's talk about that a bit
so you know there are and I've even
helped with a few movies that have been
involved with science fiction and so on
one of the sad things about movies is
that people who make them often don't do
their homework terribly well and it's
kind of a weird thing that somebody will
spend 50 million dollars on a movie and
there'll be a piece of dialogue about
science and they won't think to check it
with anybody who knows anything about
science and it will be completely goofy
but also the movies often have core
ideas and it is remarkable how often the
core ideas of these movies end up
turning into reality occasionally people
when they build technology actually copy
things of our movies so for people
who've seen like Star Trek
for instance Star Trek has these
communicators that sort of flip open so
early cell phones there was a great
moment when there were these so called
flip phones people still call them flip
phones sometimes where the thing flipped
open and that was kind of a copy of what
had been in the Star Trek television
series
back in the 1960s similarly when when
when we were when we built wolf malphur
which was initially primarily a website
and when Steve Jobs kind of put it into
Siri and so on one of the ideas was
let's imitate the Star Trek computer
let's imitate this computer that
appeared on the Star Trek television
show and movies that where you could
like ask it a question by voice and it
would start telling you answers um I
would say that some of the things well
movie that was a big favorite of mine
from like 1968 was a movie called 2001 a
Space Odyssey that was a movie about
discovery of extraterrestrial
intelligence and also about space
becoming a routine place to hang out so
to speak and I kind of did an analysis a
couple years ago of what was gotten
right in 2001 from 1968 when what was
gotten wrong so for example they had
video phones and their video phones were
kind of a little bit weird because they
looked like pay phones some of the
younger people Wichitans probably not
really even necessarily know much about
what pay phones are but there was a the
one difference was the person portrayed
showing using the video phone was doing
it from a space station and you know we
got the video phones we didn't get the
space station at least not the the
consumer space station yet um I would
say that that term you know I think the
most interesting sort of things to
explore in science fiction are sort of
the interface between humans and what
we're like and AIS and what they're like
and I would say that that there has been
I would say it's still well so one of
the interesting questions actually with
science fiction in general is what was
predicted and what wasn't what were
things that were kind of oh it's kind of
obvious this is going to happen I mean
space travel it's been kind of obvious
for a hundred years that that sort of
going to happen in some way or another
videophones it's been pretty obvious for
since the 1950s that video phones were
going to happen some way or another
something like I was I was seeing a
thing recently from 1920 talking about a
thing that was called at that time but
telly dactyl that was a television meets
thing with arms that was intended to be
a telemedicine remote medical diagnosis
station which is finally happening today
but maybe even complete with some arms
from a remote surgery and so on but you
know then there are things like for
instance I don't know the prevalence of
well things like you know social social
media it's sort of the same as things
that have existed in the past but it
wasn't really predicted it wasn't really
I think expected instead of the world of
science fiction um the idea of sort of
the web as a place where sort of
everything about humans while they the
idea that there won't be a sort of
computerized source of knowledge that
was readily accessible
that was absolutely predicted from oh I
don't know Alan Turing talked about in
1950s people got Vannevar bush talked
about it famously in nineteen forties I
think this idea that there would be this
sort of place where you could get
knowledge from a computer that was a
thing now I remember when I was a kid
there were things that oh there was the
notion that there will be teaching
machines where you just sort of would
automate the process of teaching
everything well that sort of has been
tried a bunch of times a bunch of ways
and it sort of hasn't completely worked
out um I would say I think some of the
some of the more interesting questions
have to do with you know the role of how
much of the world gets run by a is and
how does that work and how do we humans
interact with that I think that it tends
to be the case than in science fiction
there's this notion of you know the a
eyes suddenly start running amuck and
getting the idea that they're kind of
like humans and they're going to sort of
take over the world with an arm
type thing um I have a slightly more I
would say a softer view of sort of how
the AI is takeover which is you know
where many of us are used to you know
when you use the computer it will often
autosuggest
this is a thing you should do next this
is where how you should end the thing
you're typing or if you drive a car
there'll be a GPS and GPS will tell you
turn left turn right do this do that and
most of us kind of figure the computer
knows what it's doing it's usually right
it's usually what we want we'll just
drive the way it says we should drive
and I think that the you know one model
of sort of how the how a I in some sense
takes over is everything about what
we're doing ends up being something
where there's sort of an auto suggestion
about what um what should be done and we
kind of just sort of say well yeah you
know the AI kind of knows you know I've
got some little display here that's
telling me oh stop yakking about this
question there other good questions to
talk about you should move on to the
next one
and I'll just say yeah the air probably
knows what it's talking about I should
do that um so I think that's and there
are lots of things to explore about how
that works and they sort of interface
between humans and AIS which I'm not
sure have been have been fully explored
um and so yeah the hard question
actually is that there's a question here
about will there be a golden age for
science lots of science fiction talks
about golden age you know what happens
in science that I've seen is there are
many golden ages different fields go
through golden ages so for example back
when I was a kid
physics was in sort of a golden age lots
of things were being discovered an area
like biology biomedical research was
kind of like well yeah people did that
it's kind of messy there's not a lot you
can figure out it's not a very
systematic area etc etc now a sort of
systematic biological research is a big
thing it's much huger than when
something like physics and physics is is
well I'd like to think that some of the
things we're doing recently had
physics a bit more exciting again but
hasn't been so exciting for for a while
um and I think you know what tends to
happen and it tends to happen is some
methodological advanced happens some
idea for how to do things like for
example back in the day a big thing that
so launched biology was in the invention
of microscopes big thing that launched
astronomy invention of telescopes these
are these are things that these are
methodologies is a tools that let one do
things we couldn't do before so once one
has a microscope one can go look at you
know pond water all kinds of other
things under a microscope we see all
sorts of stuff and you asked for sorts
of questions you can get all sorts of
new answers and the field takes off and
what what tends to happen in my
experience so some of those
methodological advances are theoretical
things like there's this new way of
doing calculations about something
there's this new idea like in biology
recently the idea of gene editing is a
sort of a a new idea that launches a
bunch of other possibilities or the idea
that you could sequence in the genome
and get and find out what the program is
on a piece of DNA that launches a lot of
different things and what tends to
happen in my observation is that at
every every time there's a
methodological advance that's important
in some field of science that field
takes off and for some period of five 10
maybe a little bit longer years it's
very exciting and all sorts of things
are being discovered and after all of
the low-hanging fruit has been picked so
to speak then it's hard work and the
hard work can go on for 50 years a
hundred years and people often even
forget that there was a time when the
field was moving quickly and when a lot
of new ideas were being introduced and
it sort of become and say well we just
do this thing the way we do the thing
we've been doing it that way for 50
years or a hundred years or whatever so
so that you know I think that one can
expect to see a series of golden ages to
different fields now I have to say
there's a very big methodology that is
coming in and our times which is the
computational methodology and you know
I've often said that for every field X
there either is now or will be a
computational X and it will be the
that field so a computational
archaeology a computational zoology
whatever else and that you know for for
every area of science the introduction
of the computational paradigm is
something that will make all sorts of
exciting things happen and the people
who are like thinking oh I should you
know what am I going to study or do you
know computational X is a really
worthwhile thing because it is the you
know computation is this kind of new
paradigm that's just in these decades
really coming in and it's going to take
off in a bunch of different fields it's
taken off and I don't know computational
biology bioinformatics sort of took off
a number of years ago computation as a
tool in different fields taking off at
different times but that's a you know
that's a way to to see some sort of you
know those will be golden ages for
different fields I mean in terms of you
know people sometimes make the claim so
I have friends who make two kinds of
claims one claim is the rate of
knowledge is increasing exponentially
we're learning more and more and more
and you know as it's just like like
things are taking off like crazy and
another group I know say it's really
terrible nothing new is being discovered
it's it's all you know we're only going
to with the rate of innovation has gone
down to nothing okay how can both these
groups be right well the reason is that
I think that if you look at things like
academic papers the way that professors
and so on write up their research the
number of those things that get written
has been grad has been increasing very
very dramatically now is there really
and that's partly because of the
mechanisms by which people you know they
they it's it's good if you're a
professor if you publish more papers
that's a good thing you get a you know
best of position etc etc etc so it's
like there's a there's a feedback
mechanism to just publish more papers
even if the content per paper may be
going down and so that's that's so one
thing is if you look at you know how
much stuff
published in all these different areas
it's increasing its increasing even
quite dramatically okay so that makes
everything look like Oh everything's
speeding up okay the other thing is like
what new discoveries are being made well
if you say let's pick a field like
physics let's say or even something in
computational technology or whatever
else once you know the name of the field
once everybody knows the name of the
field probably that Golden Age is over
and so if you only look at fields where
you already knew about them or where for
example there's a there's a grand prize
that's being given out for that field
then yes what will happen is that you
won't see a lot of innovation happen
because those are fields that were after
their major innovative period and so so
again so it will look as if not much is
happening but where you have to look to
see really exciting things happening is
usually well maybe it's an existing
field that has some new methodology or
maybe it's a new field or maybe there's
a new methodology that cause people to
invent a newly named field alright
that's a little bit a little bit of a
complicated answer but but let's see um
gosh there's a question here about turn
from my mood about Tim Russia in the
u.s. are only a few miles apart on
location so it takes more than 10 hours
of flight time um well it reminds me of
something ok this is a silly story
perhaps not not so amusing for many when
I was a kid I don't five years old or
something some some pompous adult asks
me this was remember in the 1960s when
if you know history it was during the
Cold War when there was this big sort of
standoff between the US and what was the
Soviet Union sort of Russia and related
Contra now related countries um do you
know geographically related countries
the so this person asks me when do you
think Russia in the US will join up okay
so I think from Maryland and I say I
don't know maybe fifty thousand years
from now and the person thing that's
crazy that's a crazy answer how could
why could you say something like that
and I was like well you know I think
there are these tectonic plates that you
know there's a there's I didn't know the
details of how that worked at that time
but you know there's the North American
plate where there's a sort of rigid
piece of rock that all of North America
is on there's another one that's the
Eurasian Plate or whatever and and they
they gradually move and that's what
produces you know when when these plates
crash into each other that's what you
know Wells up to produce mountains
things like that and the
you know I knew about tectonic plates
and I knew there was sort of slow motion
of these things and so the question I
was answering was a question about some
geology the question the person was
asking was a question about geopolitics
um and so it was like an interesting
example of how one can have different
points of view about things I I am I
have no idea about
I can I can say only one thing about so
you know when you fly between two points
on the earth the question is what is the
shortest path between those two points
if you were if the earth was flat we all
know the shortest path between two
points is just a straight line the earth
isn't flat it's a sphere roughly bulges
a little bit at the equator but it's
roughly a sphere and the question is
between two points on a sphere what's
the shortest path imagine you take a
piece of string and you're pulling it on
the two ends well the shortest path is
what's called a great circle it's um
it's a it's a it's a it's a piece of a
circle that where the center of the
circle is the center of the earth so
between any two points on the earth the
shortest path is a great circle and
that's that's just measuring the number
of miles you have to go on surface of
the earth now if you're flying in a
plane there are different issues so for
example one issue is if you fly there is
typically winds prevailing winds on the
that circulate in one direction I guess
in the northern hemisphere one direction
the southern hemisphere I believe I have
to think about that moment but that's I
think that's right it's that right think
so um the in any case there are
prevailing winds that will typically
blow in one direction or another I mean
the fact that winds blow in a definite
direction is relevant like when you look
at an airport for example right airports
have runways and let's say they have
runways in certain directions planes
like to take off and land into the wind
why because they want the the even
though their wheels are only going along
the ground that lets say 100 miles an
hour 150 miles an hour something like
that they want the airflow over their
wings to be as fast as possible and so
the way you achieve that is by having
the wind blowing the head wind blowing
onto the plane like that so the so the
wind might be blowing that let's say 20
miles an hour maybe 50 miles an hour the
wind is blowing 50 miles an hour the
plane is going 100 miles an hour so that
means that these if the wind is blowing
sort of into the direction that the the
the plane is going to from the direction
the plane is going into then that means
the speed of the air over the wings will
be 100 plus 50 miles an hour hundred and
50 miles an hour and that's good because
the fast of the the the air is is
flowing over the wings the more lift the
plane will be able to get and so on so
it's able to take often where recently
without it's having to roll its wheels
faster on the ground so but that only
works if the runway for the the airport
is arranged in a direction that makes it
be the case that you can that you are
that that the wind tends to be in the
direction along the runway if the wind
was always a cross at 90 degrees to the
runway that that's bad it's actually
kind of hard to land a plane if there's
a if there's a strong wind that's
blowing 90 degrees to the runway you end
up having to tip the plane on and land
on one wheel and all sorts of elaborate
things to deal with to deal with that so
anyway the if you kind of look at a map
of sort of airports on on the earth you
can kind of see something about the
prevailing winds because of the way that
up what runways tend to be aligned and
if you look it up what runways piece of
sort of techno trivia there have big
numbers written at the two ends they're
usually two digit numbers so there'll be
like a - 8:28 written at one end and a
one zero written at the other end and
those are the those are the magnetic
headings basically the of the of the
runways and so if you fly planes it'll
be you know land on runway two eight
which means land on the runway which is
in a bearing of two hundred eighty
degrees relative to north and the reason
so around we might be to eight and one
zero
oh because going one direction it's did
I get that right go did I not get that
right to have to do my arithmetic
correctly let's see they should be 180
degrees apart yes that's right um so on
one direction what has to be the case is
it learning one way you're at a heading
of two hundred and eighty degrees so
that's that's roughly roughly west and
if you 270 will do west and if you're
going the other way on the runway
they're the heading would be let's say
if you're going east it would be ninety
so that would be so then you could have
a runway which was which would be on one
side it would say two seven on the other
side it would say 9 or 0 9 um and so
that's so if you if you if you notice on
on aerial photographs of airport runways
you'll see those numbers painted on
which could there give their directions
okay that was a very long ponderous way
of saying that even though the shortest
path between two points on the earth is
a great circle if you're flying a plane
you may not want to fly the exact great
circle path because if the wind is
blowing in a direction and the winds at
the altitude planes
fire can be really fast like 150 miles
an hour 200 miles an hour reason I think
and so it really makes a difference
since a plane is flying at maybe 500
miles an hour 5 min 50 miles an hour it
really makes a big difference if you
have a headwind
but that's you know making you go 200
miles an hour
less quickly relative to the ground
because relative to the air that the
speed of plane flies like five hundred
fifty miles an hour what the plane hat
cares about is how fast the air is
flowing over its wings and has to keep
that below something below the speed of
sound and the among other things and it
took so that's what matters for the
plane is the airspeed the speed that the
plane is flying relative to the air what
matters as far as when you get to your
destination is the ground speed how fast
the plane is flying relative to fix
points on the ground and so it depends
on the wind what the relationship
between those two things is and so you
don't necessarily want to fly in a great
circle path if the prevailing wind is in
a funny direction you might it might be
better for you since the windows do not
uniform across the whole earth it might
be better for you to fly further south
for a while then go up for the north
because you're avoiding places where the
wind is blowing in a direction that will
make you go more slowly so so that's one
reason why why planes don't fly and
create circle paths
another reason is another reason is that
another very mundane reason is that they
tend to fly from one radio navigation
beacon to another so there'll be these
beacons on the ground that um even
though nowadays planes just could know
where they are but from GPS from
satellites it's still the case that in
most places planes fly from one radio
navigation beacon the position of one
radio navigation beacon on the ground to
another one even though they're probably
knowing where they are not familial
navigation beacons but from GPS and the
final reason of course why planes don't
fly in in great circle paths and so on
is because you have to a country has to
say it's okay to fly over our airspace
or you can't do it and so it's it's
always complicated what happen
in in different places weather different
I remember when years ago the well these
days if you fly think from from London
to Tokyo I think I think those are
opposite sides of the earth and that's
sort of the question do you fly over the
u.s. so do you fly over Russia and that
I think I think it's roughly even and it
depends on the wind which way its best
bet for the plane to go but in the past
there wasn't any choice because when
there was a Soviet Union and so on they
didn't allow planes at least for a while
they didn't allow planes to fly over
their airspace and so that meant that
you had to had to go in different way
but I'm not sure I was answering the
question that was asked here um there's
a question here why and how do you know
all this mark was asking I know what
that this was but look I've spent I have
a decent memory as you guys might have
figured out by the time you've watched a
few of these some few of these things
and I I've been steadily accumulating
knowledge all my life and and now I'm an
old guy so so that's how I know stuff
and and I I did learn at one point to
flight plane so I know tiny bit about
about that although I haven't haven't
done it for them for ages okay um let's
see those questions about flying saucers
I don't know much about flying saucers
as question from Brian do you think we
will have brain implants that allow us
to access the Internet anytime soon
interesting question you know the so our
our brain the nerves in our brain the
hundred billion nerve cells in our brain
basically work electrically they're
sending signals to each other
electrically and there's sort of a
question of can we read out those
electrical signals and find out what's
going on in a brain or even can we
insert electrical signals to change what
a nerve cell is thinking so to speak in
our brains in terms of of reading out
what our brains are kind of are thinking
we can get an EEG electroencephalography
on our heads like a 12 electrodes on so
different places on that on a head and
we can we can start trying to figure out
what electrical activity is going on in
our brain actually the EEG signal is
very very poor in the sense that the by
the time each of those hundred billion
neurons is sending out a different
signal but by the time you got a great
big you know electrodes stuck on our
head it's it's it's reading out the
results of millions of more even
billions of different nerve cells and by
the time the electrical signals have
gotten through our skulls and all that
kind of thing it's it's they've been
really mushed out so so it's hard to
read from from outside the the you know
outside one's head it's hard to read a
lot of very fine detail about what the
electrical activity in the brain is what
you do see if you look at eg the the
main thing you see are these big
collective excitations there's the so
called alpha rhythm of the brain which
is at about nine nine point eight nine
nine ish cycles a second so about nine
times a second there's a sort of big
kind of increase in decrease increase in
decrease of electrical activity in the
brain that's the so called alpha rhythm
and there are things like when you go to
sleep the fatal rhythm I think starts up
and that's the different term that's a
different rhythm in the brain that's
sort of a collective phenomenon that's
happening in the brain and that's so
those are those are kind of large-scale
features of the brain I don't think it's
very clear what the Alpha rhythm is due
to I think it's it's some the it's sort
of a perhaps it's some kind of
large-scale synchronization large-scale
signaling doesn't really know and I
think what what it's due to the one
thing that can happen is if you have if
you get various kinds of brain injuries
or if you have epilepsy
the bad thing that can happen is that
there can be a kind of large-scale sort
of large scale effect on the brain where
the so-called depolarization wave where
where a whole bunch of neurons
collectively together
we'll get excited excite the K excite to
K and so you get these large-scale
effects which are which are visible on
eg eg is pretty hard to read actually
and if you go you know if you're like
trying to figure out why you're not
sleeping better and things like this you
might go to a sleep lab not sure I would
be able to sleep if I went to a sleep
lab but I'm sure they're very
comfortable but the and the hook up EEG
to your brain and then watch the the the
different waves that develop during
different stages of sleep so you know
when we sleep there are there are
different time we go through different
stages slow-wave sleep REM sleep rapid
eye movement sleep all sorts of
different things and even even went from
a little little you know Fitness watch
type accelerometer thing if you're
measuring heartrate and you're measuring
motion you can actually tell to decent
approximation how much of those
different phases of sleep you you get in
a night so actually one question we're
sort of veering off topic here but but
one question you might ask is why do we
sleep and this is one of those sort of
super obvious science questions where we
don't completely know the answer yet and
you know people have said okay one of
the more bizarre theories of why we
sleep is because evolutionarily we
evolved to to keep out of trouble during
the night okay that was a that has been
a fairly serious theory of why their
sleep because not all animals do sleep
and some animals have having weird
features like I think sharks I think
have this thing where they have two
sides of the brain and they come one
side can be asleep while the other one
is awake and you know other kinds of
animals I think I think by the time your
attempt by the time you're above insects
and things do you do have some kind of
phenomenon of sleep for most animals and
but there are ones that sleep very
little there are ones like I don't know
koalas that hang out a sleeper I don't
know 20 something hours per day and you
know there's a lot of variation in the
amount of sleep so so a question why do
we sleep
you know I have always believed that and
I've I've always thought for for ages
that we'd probably sleep to somehow rest
our brains in the same way that that if
we if we you know do things with our
muscles when we've when we tensed our
muscles so when we you know a muscles
work they're a bunch of these filaments
protein filaments and whenever the
nerves send electrical signals to our
muscles saying tense up that muscle
those those filaments sort of sort of
climb over each other and contract and
when we do that a bunch of times we
build up lactic acid and that has to
slowly sort of diffuse out and that's
that's what Tim you know you can kind of
massage your muscles to get rid of that
as a because your muscles sort of get
tired and I've always sort of assumed
that something like that must be
happening in the brain and people I know
in in neuroscience of for years told me
oh no no no it isn't like that something
different so what is it well the one
theory has been that sleep is important
for the consolidation of memories and by
the way I think the end result are is
sleep is something that biology
discovered and then lots of different
things get done during sleep and so it
isn't really for one purpose alone in
biology I mean you know another question
is do you actually need sleep and you
know you can try you know you can try
and stay awake for a super long time and
maybe you'll get to a few days when
you're awake and then pretty soon you're
you'll fall asleep but if you if you
really stop yourself from falling asleep
you'd probably only end die but not
that's not completely clear that's true
because but that term it seems to be the
case that it's really you know if you
kept yourself awake for a whole week or
something would do really bad things to
you so there are other okay so so a
theory that was popular in neuroscience
was sleep as a time when you consolidate
memories so during the day we're
bringing in all these memories where we
learned we're seeing all these things
and the idea was sleep is a time when
you sort of organize all those memories
really long-term storage possibly
possibly in effect you know there are
other things that happen if you if you
get too little sleep there lots of bad
things you get too little sleep but
another thing that happens is your
immune system doesn't work as well
whether it has to do is sleep not
particularly clear okay so another thing
that's knowin is when there is one thing
that's claimed is there's a buildup of a
substance called AD Anno seen in the
brain and i think you know one sort of
naive point of view is when a nerve cell
when their electrical pulses in nerve
cells they know cells work like little
tiny batteries and they used
electrochemistry they use chemical
processes to briefs an electrical signal
and every time there's a every time a
nerve style so nerves operate about a
thousand times a second roughly so that
they're the nerve is kind of doing
something maybe a thousand times a
second and so every time it sort of does
something produce a little electrical
pulse like a little little operation or
a battery and it produces there's a it
sort of little it produces
neurotransmitters so like one common one
is acetylcholine it's a type of
neurotransmitter and and this
neurotransmitter there other ones
serotonin dopamine things like this are
also neurotransmitters and those are
things which are part of the the
chemical part of the electrochemistry of
transmitting electrical signal from one
nerve cell to another to send two sort
of signal or another nerve cell so so
one question is whether when you have a
lot of those signaling processes
happening are you building up any
residue does is there something that is
the sort of side effect just like lactic
acid is the side effect in muscles is
there similarly a side effect an actual
chemical that is sort of a side effect
in in in the operation of the brain and
probably answer is yes and probably my
guess might be wrong although I think I
know scene is thought to be possibly
that that that thing that in sleep one
of the things that's happening is the
brain is kind of washing
out that that sort of that waste
material that has been produced as a
result of all that thinking you've been
doing during the day and you know what
happens often in sleep is so for example
in in in let's see I have to get my
sleep stages right here some stages of
sleep you kind of your muscles are
completely limp and your and other
stages of sleep you're kind of flailing
around and that's why you can detect
this stuff with with an accelerometer
but I think the you know one of one of
the theories is you know sort of a
better disconnect all the motor
functions at a time when your brain is
doing weird stuff and cleaning our up
weird things because otherwise you'll
end up doing something terrible in your
sleep so to speak and and that's why
that is better disconnected and you
might ask about dreams for example mine
allows you to person to ask about trains
further I almost never remember mine
possibly because I don't use an alarm
clock but that's very rarely but turns
who don't usually wake up in the middle
of having a dream but but you know
presumably dreams are the result of sort
of the completion that our brain does of
sort of random signals a random signal
comes in and our brain is kind of trying
to make sense of that random signal and
so we build up this whole story around
that random signal and that's and that's
how we make up sort of what we what we
have in dreams okay but I think the
original question here was about
connecting directly connecting to brains
with neural implants and things like
this so so with purely electrical
signals it's very hard to get precise
information from outside the head so to
speak with magnetic signals it's
actually a little bit easier but you
have to be in a very magnetically quiet
environment where there are no
electrical devices running around it and
so on um the alternative is actually put
something in your brain and you know for
people who have like Parkinson's disease
for example they might have a deep brain
stimulator which is something that's put
into their brain that is used to help
produce an electrical signal that um
will for
example excite areas of the brain that
produce dopamine or whatever else not
not sure muddled the details about how
that works but anyway that's a case
where once put something into the brain
and one sending signals out now there
are various attempts to make when you do
that nerve cells are pretty small and so
one of the questions is can you make
something that looks like a piece of
like a microprocessor chip with little
connections on it where those little
connections will all connect to
different nerve cells in your brain and
maybe the answer is yes no cells aren't
very keen usually on things like silicon
and so they it's hard to make that
Junction work although I think progress
has been made being made in that but
let's say you have this whole array of
of little electrical connections and
you've got nerve cells that are right up
against those electrical connections so
that you potentially could could could
both read out what the nerve cells are
doing and send back signals into the
nerve cells
that's a conceivable thing to do it's a
most immediate interest to people have
like spinal cord injuries where there
are nerves in the spinal cord that are
associated with either bringing
sensations from I don't know some part
of their body to their brain or for
sending out motor signals saying you
know move the leg move this whatever and
if the spinal cord is injured or even
severed then there's the question of can
you make something that will connect
those nerve fibers back up again it's
probably a little bit easier to think
about doing that than it is to - really
well I don't know it's easier it's it's
different from from in the case of the
brain but it's a similar kind of idea
but so then the question is you've got
this this interface which has a bunch of
bunch of electrical connections but a
bunch of nerve cells right up against
those electrical connections then the
question is okay what do those
electrical connections those nerve cells
you see that when I lift my hand some
nerve cells start producing electrical
signals but you have to learn what those
nerve cells are doing you have to learn
which nerve cells specifically are
associated with this or that and you
know in general terms brains normal
brains are laid out the same way
particularly people like me who are
left-handed their brains to get laid out
a little different
and they're often so it's some but but
you know generally you have the general
architecture of the brain you know the
visual cortex which deals with with
vision from your eyes at the back of
your head it's kind of a piece of bad
design because it means the optic nerve
has to go all the way through your brain
right to the back of your head to to get
signals processed there's the motor
strip which is somewhere up here which
is responsible for the nerve signals
that causes you to be able to move move
things you know make your muscles move
around and so on but but imagine that
you've it you've put some you know
direct neural connection into some part
of your brain first thing you got to do
is learn what are those nerves in that
part of your brain actually doing and
they'll be laid out differently for each
person maybe the general areas might be
similar but the details will be
different for each person so you know
like one thing I always thought - I
always wondered whether it be possible
to use eg to type so for example you
know the motor strip I mentioned is up
here there's a pre motor strip and and
if you measure electrical signals in the
brain you'll start seeing some amount of
of electrical activity
okay so first question is how fast so
things happen so for instance if you
have human reaction time so let's say
you know buzzer goes off you press the
button how long does that take
it takes about 300 milliseconds about
0.3 seconds the typical kind of reaction
that one has and you know if you're
really really alert and young and so I
made it a little bit shorter than that
but it's roughly 300 milliseconds 0.3
seconds three tenths of a second and and
if you work out the speed at which
nerves no signals travel what you
realize is that 300 milliseconds
correspondence to a lot of running
around for you know I forget I'd have to
work that out how it's it's like running
you know hundreds of meters sort of
inside your brain running around trying
to sort of figure out what to do in
those 300 milliseconds it's mostly not
the time necessary to
send the signal from your brain to your
finger to press that button it's mostly
stuff happening in your brain so one
question is if you could pick up the
information about what's happening in
your brain more quickly than then it
really develops us so another thing to
say is inside your brain
roughly not quite the way it works but
but if it was if our brain was more like
an electrical machine we might have
low-voltage electronics in our brains
and then high voltage Alec trying to
actually actuate something outside it
isn't quite the way it works but there's
some phenomenon like that that causes in
order to develop the signal that you
need to actually send it out on long
distance nerves it takes sort of more
effort and more time so the question is
what the so you might be able to pick up
the information about I'm going to press
that button let's say after 100
milliseconds so you'd save 200
milliseconds um so in other words if you
were typing and you wanted to type
faster you would say let's just pick up
the signal in my premotor area before
before I get the whole sort of apparatus
set up to actually tell my you know tell
the muscle and my finger to move and so
on so and so on and actually there were
experiments done particularly in the
nineteen sixties people for who were
flying military planes and so on there
was the you know could one wire up the
pilot so that the pilot would figure out
what to do more quickly than they would
do with human reaction times now you
know there's sort of the question of of
is that actually a good idea because you
know it's like oh the pilot thought
about firing a missile but they weren't
sure they were gonna fire a missile and
you know it picked it up in the premotor
area and off went the mesial even though
in another 200 milliseconds they would
have realized up no that's not a good
idea um so you know it's for that
particular application it might not be
the best thing but in any case so this
question can you and I had long thought
I'd long thought one of the advantages
of you know all one's hair falling out
might be there'd be easier to stick
electrodes on one's head and sort of
type by pure thought turns out well
still hasn't been made to work of typing
by pure thought and all
turns out those electrodes even though
they make a bit of a mess if you put
them on your hair they don't really
cause trouble laughs so in any case so
then the this is a long sort of answer
to let's say you could get these
electrodes sort of in the brain and you
could figure out what that particular
you know what that particular part of
your brain does I mean we know when
people do neurosurgery for example
they're trying to figure out you know
exactly where to where to go in the
brain so to speak that often excited
piece of the brain figure out what
effect that has on person to know oh
that's the language of the brain we
should avoid that area or whatever else
so so it's some so it's kind of knowing
you can sort of you can excite pieces of
the brain find out what the effect they
have and kind of get an idea of how the
brain is is laid out and one could
imagine using machine learning and
that's been tried for for some of these
things like spinal cord mechanisms and
so on to figure out you know how what is
the mapping of how which nerve fiber
goes with what thing um and and some of
it is fairly direct I mean like in the
visual cortex there's a fairly direct
layout of the the different pieces of
your visual scene a fairly directly laid
out as actual at least the first level
of visual cortex as actual sort of
locations on the visual cortex and so so
the any case so so the first thing is
can you figure out what the brain is how
the brain works but figuring out sort of
more abstract thoughts a little bit more
difficult I think you know it's been a
long-running question is there a place
in the brain where you think about I
don't know Brussels sprouts or something
will you think about apples versus
oranges long-running question and though
these experiments done with functional
MRI functional magnetic resonance
imaging where you go in an MRI scanner
and somebody says think of an honor
image think of an apple and then one
looks at the the activity of the brain
in different areas that you try to map
out if
somebody thinks of an orange where does
it light up in the brain if somebody
thinks of an apple where does it light
up in the brain those tend to be very
very cost things it's very difficult to
know it's very unlikely that that there
is a just this point in the brain this
particular neuron that says I'm the
Apple neuron another neuron that says
I'm the I'm the orange neuron so to
speak it's very unlikely that we encode
information in that kind of spatially
localized way and in fact it's become
much clearer because we use artificial
neuron that's now for lots of kinds of
machine learning things we kind of know
how those work and it just doesn't work
that way it's the the knowledge of a
concept is spread out across across lots
of different artificial neurons and
probably that's the way it works in
human brains as well the knowledge of a
concept is some very complicated
assembly of different kinds of of
connections between different nerve
cells and not something where you can
say oh that's the you know if I were
only to to to sort of excite that
particular neuron in the brain you'd
think of an orange and that particularly
neuron you'd think of an apple it's much
more complicated than that
and that makes it much more difficult to
imagine having an interface where you
would say because you there might be in
the concept of an orange there might be
excitation of a million neurons involved
in the concept of an orange and so to
give you the thought of the concept of
an orange you'd have to be exciting
across those across those million
neurons and that's a much more difficult
thing to do
so so I think the answer to - when will
we'll be able to get complicated
thoughts transmitted to our brains that
way I think it's tough I think that's
going to be difficult getting something
like I'm thinking of a letter and that
you know you might learn because because
if you're doing the type by thought
type thing there's sort of two sides of
that there's one is the system kind of
you know being able to recognize what's
going on your brain the other is your
brain knowing you being able to train
yourself
oh and this is something that's that's
done for people who aren't able to
communicate in other ways they can start
to train themselves to
have various kinds of brain activity
that can be read out that means
something like yes or no or whatever
else and so I think you know between us
learning how to do it getting something
like being able to pick out you know
letters on a keyboard yeah that's
something one can imagine doing being
able to get sort of the full here's a
web page I'm going to ingest it directly
into my brain that seems really tough I
mean I think the the set up of our eyes
and our brains and and by the way you
might say can I just take the the
thought pattern you know person A's
thought pattern and inject it into
person B it's just not going to work
because the detailed way that our brains
possible the way our brains are laid out
and second of all the way we actually
encode knowledge in our brains is
completely different between different
people and that the reason for that is
the encoding will depend on everything
we learned in our lives so unless two
people that had the exact precise same
experiences they are not going to have
encoded knowledge in the same way in
their brains and so just saying here's
this block of memory is this neuron
number of 3214 had a was encoded point
seven and neuron this encoded this and
so on there won't be a mapping where you
can just say take the neuron map from
one person stick in another person
that's not going to work so the idea
that there's sort of a a transfer of
thinking from person to person not their
work for a eyes if you had to absolutely
identical a eyes you can do that kind of
transfer and actually in machine
learning it's really common to to use a
method called transfer learning which
uses a sort of a layer of learning where
you have learnt sort of hounds something
about how to learn where one AI has
learnt something about how to learn how
to recognize features about something
and be able to just use that as a as a
preprocessor for another AI but for us
humans that's you know it's not gonna
work that way I mean for us humans by
the way there are things that could
happen so one interesting thing that
could happen is so right now augmented
reality hasn't really caught it on its
own mental reality is something where
you sort of toy versions of it but you
know and Pokemon go or something I
suppose as a version of it where well
it's like you know you might wear some
special glasses where we're superimposed
on your visual field and what you're
normally looking at is some other stuff
maybe some annotation maybe it would be
you know there's a picture of I don't
know the you know the camera that I'm
looking at right now and it might have a
little arrow going to it that says
camera okay that's very helpful if I
already knew that but it might say you
know it might have it was a person it
might say oh this is the name of the
person if you forgot that you know it's
a caption for your for what you see in
your Raziel field so one of the things I
could imagine happening is kind of a
preprocessor for our full for our vision
system that helps us with things so it's
already we have that a little bit if you
have a like a night vision system in a
car you might have something where by
your CD well it's seeing in the infrared
so it's able to see you know there's an
animal that's just ran into the road and
it's hot and so shows up as this big
thing that is superimposed on your
ordinary you know on ordinarily what
you're seeing through the windshield but
we can imagine more elaborate versions
of that we can imagine something where
for example I don't know the well for
example with infrared it's like you know
if you as if there's a hot plate in
front of you and you know we might not
we can't tell just by looking at it is
it hot unless it's got some steaming
thing on it or something but normally we
couldn't tell if it was hot but on the
other hand if we have a camera that is
looking at it and has it sensitive to
infrared which is radiant heat um then
then the Carroll say oh yeah that's a
hot thing and it could superimpose
something on our normal visual field
showing this big sort of you know
warning warning you know that's a hot
plate or something so so I can imagine
things which are a little bit like this
sort of transfer learning mechanism of
of knowing that's being used for humans
but pretty external to our brain
I don't think sort of having things that
the directly interface with our brain is
all that likely to work I
unfortunately have to go fairly soon and
there's so many interesting questions
here this is some um as a question here
is it true that only left-handed people
are in their right to mind so to speak i
I've said various times that I happen to
be left-handed you know it's that's
that's a slightly funny claim because it
turns out you know there's left
handedness there's left footed nurse
there's left handedness for small
motions there's left handedness for
large motions I'm a weird hybrid I'm for
small motions like writing with a pen
I'm left-handed but for bigger things I
tend to be more right-handed so the
weird hybrid case I don't know what that
means about the how my brain is set up
it's probably really scrambled um okay
ah because the question here from have
we thought about adding augmented
reality into things like wolf an alpha
um you know it's funny people are asking
earlier about Golden Ages of Technology
the idea of virtual reality that is of
being able to you know wear some goggles
or something and have a visual
experience that is kind of like the
visual experience you would have if you
were just out there in the room that's
the thing that people sort of thought
might be just around the corner since
the late 1980s you know what happened
with sound back when I was a kid you
know you could be listening to a concert
for real so to speak or you could be
playing a record and it was totally
different know that the sound quality
was totally different but nowadays you
know if you have your big fancy
headphones you've got digital sound and
so on you will hear a sound in your ears
that is basically a perfect imitation of
the sound you would hear anywhere else
and so you know for sound we've pretty
much managed to get it so that you can
deliver digitally the perfect sound
experience that is no different from
sort of just being there so to speak the
provision we're not yet there and you
know we can kind of see why there's but
for our ears we have our auditory nerve
has about 50,000 fibers in it and that's
kind of the amount of information that's
being transmitted to our brains Mar ears
or optic nerve has about 10 million
fibers in it so there's a lot more
information that's coming from our eyes
than from our ears so it's more data
that you need in order to be able to
accurately reproduce a sort of a visual
C than an auditory scene and we're not
quite there yet and you know one of the
biggest uses we have a certain amount of
peripheral vision to the sides and when
you're looking at a computer display
you're not getting that peripheral
vision and you're also getting you know
as you turn your head there's a question
of does the scene that you see you know
if it's just stuck on a computer screen
it behaves differently and so on and so
on and so on and so so there's been sort
of this question about can you have
these sort of head mounted displays that
we'll be able to give you the appearance
of being really in a visual environment
and that's been getting progressively
better but at different times in sort of
technology history it's been we're just
about to be there and VR virtual reality
is gonna be really really big and that
happened in the early 1990s
actually it was I remembered the demos
of VR i remember playing a a ping pong
you know tennis type game in VR and
remember seeing them i'm not very good
at that but it's okay i was i was the
okay indian are at least um the and I
remember sort of architectural
walkthroughs you know this is the
building we're going to build walk
through it in virtual reality to get a
sense of what it will seem like so you
know it seemed like dr was just about to
take off in the early 1990s and then
didn't take off and you know i think the
technology the hardware wasn't quite
good enough and then a few years ago it
seemed like VR was just about to take
off again it was gonna be really really
big and it's still again you know people
use it and it's okay but it hasn't
really taken off it hasn't really gotten
to the point where people routinely use
it and maybe it will and there's a lot
of issues about you know could you do
video conferencing in VR could you know
that's a little weird because you've got
this thing attached to your head that is
and you know how does it see you well
you can do very weird things where you
have sort of cameras inside the goggles
looking at your eyes and and they're
sort of making up a fake version of what
your face would look like if your face
was actually exposed to the person at
the other end and so on there's all
kinds of funky ideas like that um that
might or might not work um but so you
know I think it's one of these things
where there are a lot of interesting
applications for particularly I think
for augmented reality I mean it's kind
of like one of these sort of fashion
statement type things it's like you know
wearing glasses these days I don't think
is terribly cool and you know kids often
want to get you know contact lenses or
something because they do not want to
wear glasses even though they're very
good for protecting your eyes if nothing
else um
the but you know by the time there's
augmented reality then suddenly glasses
will be absolutely in fashion because
you'll need them too as a place to mount
some augmented reality display thing
maybe they'll be augmented reality
contact lenses but I really doubt it and
that would look so weird seeing looking
at somebody and seeing you know on their
eyes so to speak seems to me kind of
display thing which would probably be
able to see if it was a larger display
maybe a little weird own glasses to I'm
not sure but I think you can arrange the
optics so that you wouldn't see that all
right I think I have to run off because
I have a completely different thing to
do um and this was fun for me at least
as always and hope people found it
interesting and I will plan to do this
again next week
and I know we've got some lots of
questions that assembled here and I
didn't get a chance to go through them
and maybe we can do some of those next
week so thanks a lot